you have great ideas inside you you know
you're capable of more you know you want
to serve you know you want to help and
great ideas are flowing through you and
we shut them off because we find a
logical reason why we can't do it
whatever logical excuse that we come up
with that's listen it's based in reality
you're a smart person you wouldn't
believe a stupid reason so the reasons
that we're listening to are actually
based on some kind of fact but they're
still an excuse and underneath it
underneath that reason why you can't do
something is because you're afraid
you're afraid I'm afraid we're afraid of
taking the next step and the fear
underline that is not the fear of it not
working out it's the fear of it not
working out and who's going to see you